ranking member the House Intelligence
Committee Adam Schiff we want to listen
to that QA the decision has been made by
the committee itself to vote out this
memo that was produced by the
Republicans on that committee looking at
classified material about surveillance
during the campaign here is just a
compilation earlier of some lawmakers
whether this memo should be released or
not it certainly should be but somebody
should explain how utterly insignificant
it is this memo answers what I think are
really legitimate questions and I do
think the FBI should look at it before
before it is released so I want to play
face/off poker no I don't want it
released yet I don't I want somebody
who's without a political bias to come
in and look at the allegations that I've
seen the way the FBI conducted itself in
the Department of Justice bothers me no
one at the White House has actually seen
the memo so it would be hard for us to
make a decision other lawmakers say they
are tremendously disturbed by what they
see in this memo and want to get it out
that's the position that the committee
has taken tonight voting along party
lines to do just that
we're gonna bring in our panel early Tom
Bevan RealClearPolitics co-founder and
publisher Molly Hemingway senior editor
at the Federalist and Charles Lane
opinion writer for The Washington Post
okay Molly we wanted to let that breathe
a little bit to get the details of kind
of behind the scenes the committee
voting to release the Republican memo
but the Democratic memo voting not to
release it at this moment yes and I mean
this is a summary memo this is a
four-page memo that is just a summation
of a year's worth of work hundreds of
thousands of pages of testimony and
visits to foreign countries and speaking
with all sorts of people
what broke today about McCabe Andrew
McCabe the number two at FBI stepping
down suggest that we have a pretty big
situation on our hands he's only the
most recent person to be demoted stepped
down or be reassigned after
congressional or other inquiries into
some of what was happening over there at
FBI you had Bruce or who was demoted
twice you had Peter struck who had to be
taken off the case
you have Baker who was taken who was
who's gone and right
riki also so this is this is quite a
collection of people obviously there's
something huge going on and I think a
lot of people in the media are just kind
of missing this very large story perhaps
this memo will help help us learn a
little bit more about what it is that's
causing all of these changes sometime
the Deputy Director McCabe leaves today
who's scheduled to retire mid-march
leaves today kind of abruptly we had
sources saying that you could say that
he was removed the New York Times
changed its headline and said that he
stepped down under pressure and this
graph in a recent conversation
Christopher Rea the FBI director raised
concerns about a forthcoming Inspector
General report examining the actions of
mr. McCabe and other senior FBI
officials during the 2016 presidential
campaign when the bureau was
investigating both Hillary Clinton's
email use and Trump campaigns connection
to Russia in that discussion according
to one former law enforcement official
close to mr. McCabe mr. ray suggested
moving mr. McCabe into another job which
would have been a demotion all of this
factoring in the day after ray reads
this memo up on Capitol Hill and as
Britt said earlier it could be a
coincidence but at this point it's
probably safe to assume there are no
coincidences with regard to this
situation I think Molly's right this is
a big deal the fact that the number two
at the FBI has has been removed stepped
down whatever you want to say I think
the release of the memo which is going
to come in the next few days it appears
most likely that we're gonna we're gonna
see this is going to shed some light a
lot of light on on why he stepped down
and what's been going on behind the
scenes at the FBI the partisan look at
this the fact that this is a long party
lines the fact that two different
lawmakers from two parties can look at
the same thing and see something
directly different an opposite is
striking I was struck by Lindsey Graham
who said I want someone without a
political bias to look at this before
it's released and my thought was where
is he gonna find that someone without a
political bias because the situation is
so polarized around this ted Lieu who's
a ultra liberal democrat has said this
is going to wind up like Al Capone's
vault or whatever it is you're gonna
walk in and there's nothing there it's a
big nothing burger other people are
saying the Republicans is the most
disturbing
abuse of authority they've ever seen
it's supposed to bear just to refresh
everyone's memory on the question of
whether this steel dossier influenced
the issuance of a FISA warrant against a
member of Trump's campaign or not and
that's a diss to rewind the steel
Christopher steel is the British spy who
was hired by fusion GPS a company that
received money from the Hillary Clinton
campaign and the DNC to do Oppo research
right and so what I will be looking for
in this document to make my own judgment
is do they really have a smoking gun on
that do they can they really show that
that fight if not for the steel dossier
this FISA warrant would not have been
issued that would be a big deal if it's
anything a little bit more murky than
that I think we're gonna still have
arguments I think memo is better thought
of as something that begins a discussion
about these things for instance it's not
just about whether the FISA application
was based solely on this memo are on
this dossier but if it were used at all
if this opposition research document
paid and funded by the Hillary Clinton
campaign know if they know you know that
Andrew McCabe said recently that there
was nothing in that dossier that was
verified other than publicly available
information so if that was used in any
way that's a pretty serious situation
also there were other ways the dossier
was used information in it was briefed
to members of Congress and of course it
was also the basis for this entire
whisper campaign about treasonous
collusion between Trump and Russia it
was the fact of that dossier being
briefed to President Trump and President
Obama and then quickly leaked to enough
to a media outlet that kind of created
this whole hysteria that we've been
subjected to for a year so there are a
lot of questions and a lot of questions
about what senior FBI officials were
doing playing around with this and and
the fact that we're not even talking
about the Inspector General's report
which also should be coming out very
soon whether we get to see it or not
right it's going to be there right which
which in many respects would carry more
weight than either a partisan memo from
the from the Republicans or a partisan
memo from the Democrats but let's
release everything let's let's have the
public have the information remember the
argument to release to publish the
dossier right from CNN and from BuzzFeed
a year ago was that this is something
that you know had effect inside the
government with the FBI and the
president that same argument can be used
to
the memo from Republicans from Democrats
and also the Inspector General's report
let's see it all let's let the public
make their determination determination
about what's in those documents I
mentioned that the New York Times kind
of changed its headline through the day
as they got more information about the
McCabe step-down but another piece has
that this memo hints towards Rosen Stein
the Deputy Attorney General as being in
in the target basically and he is the
person who could get rid of Muller right
and he I guess the idea there is he
renewed the FISA warrant after he got
into office application against Carter
page right which could cut either way
could show that a member of the very own
Trump administration thought it was a
valid FISA warrant so I don't know
whether he's in trouble with the
president or he's in trouble with the
president's critics we'll have to find
out on this point of why the interaction
between the IG report and mccabe
stepping down you know the president or
Jeff Sessions had been reported to be
pressuring ray very hard to get rid of
mccabe a week ago and it could almost be
that ray is sort of seized on this IG
report to finally give jeff sessions
what he wanted and so i'm even not clear
whether it could both be true that
there's criticism of mccabe in the IG
report and that it's somehow being used
it as an excuse to pressure him out a
little bit before he wanted to go and we
should all remember he only had four
more weeks to go anyway he's still gonna
draw his paycheck so in terms of the
actual difference this makes of the FBI
it's not that great
a lot of breaking news we took the
Democrats who came to the microphones
they're outside the House Intelligence
Committee meeting that just had that
vote we have not seen the Republicans or
had any sign of the committee chairman
Devin Nunez